the Medical Aid in dying Bill currently
sitting on Governor Joe Lombardo's desk
the clock is ticking will he sign or
veto it eight news now reporter Joshua
peguero Joins us live from The Newsroom
with both sides Joshua
hello Sasha and Vanessa the Republican
Governor has until Monday to make a
decision on this bill before it becomes
law until one is made each side is vying
to get his attention
the Catholic church and the Nevada
Catholic conference holds a position
that God Alone is the author of life and
the sole operator of death Monty Chavez
co-director of the Nevada Catholic
conference says Senate Bill 239 tramples
values held by the Roman Catholic Church
for thousands of years the bill passed
by only one vote in the state senate in
April but had more support in the
assembly one of the common arguments
that is brought up is that there's
safeguards with this bill right and in
every state or country where this has
passed gradually those safeguards got
removed 11 states have legalized medical
Aid in dying qualifying patients must be
18 years old deemed mentally competent
and diagnosed terminal with six months
or less to live by two different doctors
Linda Brooks Bracey supports Nevada's
Bill diagnosed with terminal cancer
she's currently undergoing experimental
treatment I happen to be a Christian and
have a great belief in God in my faith
and I don't believe for me in my faith
that God asks me for excessive suffering
that's not the God that I know Brooks
Bracey says most terminally ill people
are trying to survive as long as they
can and SB 239 would only serve as the
last option she employs on Governor
Lombardo to sign the bill he's invited
to my home to see what my family and
other families in Nevada have to go
through the last weeks of their lives
now SB 239 will also ensure that if
someone goes through this death it
wouldn't be listed as a suicide but as
terminal illness at hand Sasha
and we are approaching the last few days
of the legislative session Republican
Governor Joe Lombardo has vetoed two
dozen bills passed by the
democrat-controlled legislature